oh Bitcoin Believers are breaking out
the bubbly right now the crypto of
record has finally reclaimed thirty
thousand dollars it's taken 305 days but
Bitcoin officially breached that level
for the first time since June in the
last 24 hours right now look at it it's
at 30
419 and at a pretty much a yeah it's at
the 24-hour high that is for sure now of
course it's nowhere near bitcoin's
record high of
69044 hit back in November of 2021 but
bitcoin's boost has sent crypto related
stock searching I mean just look at
coinbase block Riot Marathon all are
charging higher today uh you know what
block is just about a third of a percent
higher but the rest of them I mean Riot
up 17
marathon of 14 coinbase up six percent
Bitcoin was the best and we've told you
this before the best performing asset in
the first quarter of this year could the
crypto see back-to-back quarterly wins
and what's gonna make that happen let's
bring in one of the most well-known
names in the crypto game
pump Investments Anthony pompliano here
in a fox business exclusive well let's
tackle that first do you think that
it'll see a second quarter win as well
best performing asset just like in the
first quarter
yeah thanks so much for having me I
understand that people want to kind of
talk about week to week performance
month-to-month performance but I think
that Bitcoin is a unique asset in that
it forces people to be a long-term
thinker about it and if you really look
over uh the last couple of years is
there's been incredible volatility we've
seen prices go up hundreds of percent
we've seen drawdowns that have been 50
to 75 percent and so the people who end
up kind of winning by holding the asset
are folks who use Timeless investing
principles they dollar cost average into
an asset they hold it for a long time
and it happens to be the trade of this
generation if you go back 20 years ago
the winners and losers were pretty much
determined by who bought the internet
stocks and who didn't and if you could
hold the right ones for a long time you
ended up having outsized returns and so
I think that the trade of this
generation is going to be who bought
this asset and who didn't now you got to
hold it for a long period of time and
you can't get sucked up into that
day-to-day volatility but if you follow
those Timeless investing principles so
far those people tend to be doing pretty
well well who yeah who bought it at 15
000 because now it has double I see your
point there but what do you think has
been the real driver we hear everything
about all the regional banking crisis
because you know obviously the original
intent of Bitcoin when it was created by
Satoshi Nakamoto you know whoever
whatever that really was uh was that
people no longer trusted the central
bank or regular Banks is it that is it
something much much longer in the past
perhaps is it inflation what do you
think
yeah I think people want a black and
white answer but the short answer is
like it's everything right and what I
mean by that is I think that the debt
limit crisis there are a lot of people
who are saying how do I hedge a
potential U.S default well if I needed
something outside of the system I need
an alternative Bitcoin can help solve
that there's people who say hey I need
something that will hedge me from
currency to basement I need something
outside of the system Bitcoin can solve
that I think there's people who say hey
I need to hedge the risk around the
banking system I need something outside
of the system I need an alternative
Bitcoin can solve that and so you can go
through all of these kind of cracks in
that Legacy system and again I don't
think majority of people are taking a
hundred percent or even 50 of their net
worth and they're buying Bitcoin I very
much think that the majority of folks
are going and they're putting some
percentage maybe one to five percent
into Bitcoin and they're saying this is
the chaos hedge this is the insurance in
case there are significant issues in
that Legacy system well and what is
fascinating to me is that that system
now has been adopted by over 150 million
people around the world and so if you
think about that you could line up every
single American citizen and about one
out of every two of them now believe
that this system is worthy of some
portion of the economic value that
they've earned in their life which is
absolutely incredible to only be you
know 15 years or so into this but but
Anthony you talk about significant trust
issues uh we just saw this in November
with FTX The cryptocurrency Exchange
that completely collapsed filed for
bankruptcy block fi also having trouble
silvergate had to close its Bank what
about the trust issues there
I think that if you go and you ask
people in the Bitcoin and cryptocurrency
Industry they are not trying to bet on
the trust of centralized institutions
the banks are centralized many of those
companies use described are centralized
as well but Bitcoin specifically is a
decentralized asset with a programmatic
monetary policy it is backed by the
strongest Computing Network in the world
and if there is one thing in the world
that I will bet my life on it is the
fact that bitcoin's monetary policy will
continue to execute exactly as designed
no one in the Legacy Financial system
can even tell me what the federal
reserve's monetary policy is going to be
a month or a couple of weeks from now
you it's impossible to plan the average
American cannot plan their life the
average entrepreneur cannot plan their
business because they don't know if the
cost of capital is going to be zero
percent or five percent they don't know
if we're going to be in a quantitative
tightening or quantitative easing but
bitcoiners know the monetary policy till
the day they die it is written in code
audited by anyone in the world and as
long as that code continues to execute
that monetary policy will not change and
that is the beauty is that you can trust
an algorithm just as you do in the rest
of your life you trust Google to give
you answers rather than ask your friend
you trust Spotify to give you music
recommendations rather than ask a friend
you trust Google Maps to give you
directions rather than ask a friend and
eventually I think you're going to trust
an algorithm with your monetary policy
more than you're going to trust any
other human in the world oh well you
just bet you're live Anthony
okay we got to have you back because I
wanted to talk about xrp that's up 50
plus percent year-to-date there's news
on ethereum we've got the Shanghai uh
the company an upgrade in Shanghai that
released 33 billion in token assets so
much more to come on that thank you so
much for joining us
absolutely thanks for having us anytime